le dr karl weiss est avec nous bonsoir
dr weiss bon sa patrie alors d'abord un
petit mot parce que le docteur tardif a
besoin d'eux je disais à la blague c'est
le seul qui cherche absolument entre en
contact avec des gens qui ont la coved
19 mai ils ont besoin de 600 malades
pour tester la colchicine on veut
remettre le numéro de téléphone
d'ailleurs à l'écran pour ceux qui ont
été testées positives voici le numéro de
téléphone alors vous vous est ce que
vous vous avez aussi beaucoup d'espoir
non pas pour guérir mais pour atténuer
les symptômes les plus graves avec la
colchicine je le sais pas il faut faire
des études cligner que je suis vraiment
pas un expert de la colchicine je sais
que la colchicine a été utilisé surtout
pour des maladies cardiaques avec son
effet anti inflammatoire
initialement c'est un médicament qu'on
utilisait pour la goutte alors moi la
colchicine j'en ai prescrit lorsque
j'étais hésitant médecine interne et que
mes patients avaient de la goutte
ça remonte à pas mal longtemps donc ce
n'est un vieux médicament est ce qu'il
ya des effets bénéfiques j'en ai aucune
espèce d'idée c'est pour ça qu'il faut
faire des études bien fait bien encadrés
pour savoir si un bénéfice avec cette
molécule
bon ben ce par oullins et puis on vers
des masques je veux vous entendre sur
les masses parce que là et aux états
unis est ici à des gens qui connaissent
bien le mouvement qui commence déjà
commencé à dire on devrait être en tout
temps se balader avec un masque qui est
enfin briquet avec du tissu non pas pour
pour protéger les zones non pas pour se
protéger tellement nous mais protéger
les eaux qu'est ce que vous vous en êtes
où dans votre réflexion sur le port du
masque
alors écoutez si vous entendez parler
les chinois qui ont une expérience
la première avec le masque il faut dire
aussi qu'en asie dans les cultures le
port du masque est quelque chose qui est
bien implanté dans les sociétés donc le
responsable de la santé publique
chinoise avait récemment dit qu'en chine
il avait favorisé le port universel du
mas à tout le monde
est ce que c'est une possibilité ben si
c'est certainement une chose à laquelle
il faut penser mais avant de parler il
faut avoir des basques le cdc aux états
unis commencent à penser à recommander
les utiliser quelque chose ou on se
cacherait le visage donc une écharpe ou
quelque chose de ce titre pour empêcher
que les gens qui seraient infectés
puisse transmettre si vous voulez ou
diminuer la transmission à d'autres
alors dans un monde idéal si la capacité
d'avoir des masses qui était infini et
illimité ce serait un outil
supplémentaire pour dire on peut essayer
de porter des masques mais je vous
dirais là le fait que tout le monde ne
doit pas sortir les gens soient en
confinement
quand on demande à faire une
distanciation sociale etc
dans un contexte comme ça l'utilité du
mas est probablement moins grand que
s'il y avait alors il faut encore se
rappeler que le mas comme toutes les
autres mesures tout seul ne sont pas des
panacées et c'est l'addition des mesures
les une mise avec les autres qui va
faire pour le rallye n'est pas très bien
première question du public docteur vrai
c'est ce que le virus aurait pu
apparaître ailleurs qu'en chine
pourquoi l'a précisé mme as un big bang
biologique qui est partie de la chine
dans alors le virus est probablement à
paris en chine c'est ce que tout le
monde s'entend à dire actuellement je
tendrais pas dans les discussions en
politique entre les chinois et les
américains de qui aurait fait quoi
mais on sait que c'est un virus qui a
son origine chez les chauves-souris et
on sait que ce virus là vont avoir un
intermédiaire qui est un autre mammifère
et on pense que les marchés en chine
ce pont souvent des milieux ans dans
environnementaux adéquat pour ce genre
de transmission là on le sait avec
l'influent st on a vu avec le strass
numéro un
donc oui il ya eu l'histoire de la
civette et on assez fort probable que ce
marché est apparu à partir de
chauves-souris qui ont trouvé un
intermédiaire animal mammifères et qui
s'est propagée à l'homme par la suite
ces marchés où il ya des animaux vivants
tout à fait voilà
question 3 est ce que je peut réutiliser
les lingettes désinfectantes après les
avoir s'est remplie dans l'alcool à 70
pour ça j'aimerais utiliser au lieu
d'acheter beaucoup de questions sur
comment désinfecter ça revient ça
revient servier ouais c'est je vous
dirais que c'est probablement pas très
utile de faire ce genre de choses là
si vous voulez économiser vous êtes
mieux utiliser des grosses bouteilles
d'alcool isopropylique et à 70% en
montant et les tout simplement imbibé
des nains jette et les utiliser par la
suite plutôt que d'utiliser des nuages
est en plus à utiliser beaucoup de la
jette c'est pas très bon pour
l'environnement parce que faut les jeter
puis après ça ça créer d'autres
problèmes donc à la limite si vous
voulez utiliser un linge et ça dépend
pour quoi mais disons vous sortez deux
ordres
vous voulez tout simplement aller
nettoyer vos affaires à ce moment là
vous pouvez utiliser une lingette avec
tout simplement de l'alcool puis
nettoyer l'environnement puis réutilisé
cet aspect lors le en le lavant
je pense que l'idée c'est d'utiliser de
l'alcool parce que c'est ça qui est
l'acte le principe actif la lingette
c'est quelque chose de luxueux on va
dire très bien et ça bloque les égouts
j'aimerais connaître l'efficacité des
respirateurs je vous ai déjà posé la
question mais elle revient beaucoup
parce que et ça donne de l'espoir qui et
quel état d' quand l'état d'un patient
des sites cet outil quelles sont ses
chances de guérir
écoutez si c'est un patient relativement
bonne forme c'est à dire des gens qui
avait pas trop de maladies sous jacentes
qui sont pas très très âgées si on est
capable de les faire passer au travers
de la phase aiguë de la maladie
souvent ça va tirer une dizaine de jours
à peu près ces gens là peuvent récupérer
très adéquatement
donc les gens qui sont sur ventilateur
et qui n'ont pas d'autre condition
qu'ils vont se surajouter donc des gens
n'ont pas de cancer qui ont pas de
problèmes cardiaques majeurs qui n'ont
pas de problèmes au niveau de leurs
actions par dialyse et caetera et qui
n'ont pas de problèmes pulmonaires trait
majeur surtout s'ils sont on va dire
dans la tranche d'âge entre 60 et 75 ans
ces gens là et les plus jeunes encore
plus ces gens là bas quand vous les
mettez sur ventilateur excepté la
difficulté que tout ce que ça implique
l'eure l'eure l'eure leurs capacités
leurs champs
le survie sont très grandes non mais
faut le dire merci craint-on une
mutation du virus qui sera encore plus
difficile à stopper
alors moi je sais mon avis personnel si
le virus mute il a le goût qui va lutter
pour un virus qui est entre guillemets
moins dangereuse vernir pourquoi parce
que ce virus là est en train de
s'adapter à l'espèce humaine
c'est-à-dire chaque fois qu'il infecte
les humains il s'adapte à l'espèce
humaine est l'espèce humaine s'adapte au
virus aussi donc il faut partir du
principe qu'on avait un virus totalement
inconnu pour l'espèce humaine est un
virus qui lui ne connaissait pas
l'espèce humaine
donc l'objectif d'un virus primaires
c'est se reproduire pour se reproduire
c'est d'infecter le plus possible de
gens pour pouvoir continuer à se
reproduire
or si un virus devient trop
problématique est trop dangereux à ce
moment là il devient trop virulent il
devient plus difficile c'est autres et
il a plus de titulaires faut pas besoin
nous il ya besoin de nous donc à la
limite le virus si vous voulez avec le
temps et les humains avec le temps
devrait s'adapter l'un à l'autre donc la
tendance c'est qu'on aurait un virus qui
pour cible le mans va devenir ont failli
mais moins dangereux
trèbes la grille c'est bien jeune
dernière qu'est ce c'est celle qui est
revenu le plus souvent depuis hier je
les pose à dr carignan je vous la pose
parce que c'est pas tout le monde qui
était heureusement qui suivent nos cinq
heures d'émission bientôt les insectes
piqueurs vont arriver maringouins est
moche et cetera pourront-ils nous
transmettent le virus alors c'est pas un
virus qui est transmis par les piqûres
d'insectes en tout cas y'a vraiment rien
qui a été rapporté l'attend c'est
pourquoi il faut savoir aussi que c'est
arrivé dans des pays dans le monde avec
des températures chaudes et il n'y a pas
eu de transmission pareil par des
piqûres d'insectes dans ces pays là donc
c'est vraiment pas une voix qu'on
devrait y pensera laquelle on devait
penser actuellement très bien dr weiss
merci de comme je disais que dr car il y
en a assez de vrais problèmes on
s'ajoutera pas les moustiques
parce que ça sera pas s'ajoutera pas à
notre à notre crise là dessus vous êtes
très gentil docteur carl maes merci
courage et à très bientôt
au revoir